Hey spent a long time this is actually
metal if it's been more than a year that
haven't made any video and some people
were wondering why and I just I just
took some time off to think about
something to say and I just makes them I
just wrote some scripts here that I
wanted to share with you this is the
first video but I will make some other
is here
and I will read the stacks which is also
the script that I'm going to deliver to
all those want it bathroom at the
YouTube well this video is called active
learning against vs passive learning hi
again YouTube viewers it's really been a
few months into last five minute video
and seven four I took the liberty of
making another one and some others will
come later on a delicate subjects such
as language learning I want to say again
that there are really no scholars about
this subject but I've been learning
languages by I myself am NOT a scholar I
need there are some scholars for that
I'm not dollar but other learning
languages by this house until 13 as an
experienced old self learner I came to
the conclusion that there is no one's
best method but some universal
principles one can stick to in what you
think should be shared for the benefit
of all those really want to learn
foreign languages the proper way start
off the wrong food can lead to disaster
that is frustration and given up the
whole thing it is mandatory compulsory
to know how to get started the brisk
phase which can last six months to one
year depending on the complexity of the
target language and your previous
experience is definitely the most
delicate part creating for quick
proficiencies dangerous skills because
it keeps you from concentrating focusing
on your studies it is like a writer
still thinks he's got good speed cool
metres to go instead of staying focused
on the track step by step thinking
they've got such a long distance to
cover getting mentally tired since the
very beginning I'm sure that many of you
your learner's that thing and mowing off
your language studies and had some
reverie about yourself that being fluent
speakers and communicating flawless e in
the language are learning I did that in
worse times when I was learning through
my thought how incredible would it be if
I spoke with my much jointly that God
makes doubt about my teacher success in
that I had often around six seven months
after starting this language a little
bit frustrated cuz I wasn't fluent yet
how could I be point after six months at
that time I had no real experience
and that thought could easily frustrate
me I want to explain to you now why he
thought don't disturb me anymore
sure when I'm learning the languages
section in Chinese as I'm doing now I've
come to the conclusion that if you do a
quality work the results will be
terrific in the long run whereby long
run I mean that you have to be positive
about the fact that there will come a
point where the knowledge that you've
been accumulating will explode will take
off the so called at the same point
according to someone official literature
this threshold and the set is called if
it's a point after that point you find
yourself speaking much much better than
you had done before it's just like a
curve you just prepare yourself to get
to certain point and then it goes up
exponentially
you don't alive what you're happy about
it of course I'm sure some of you know
what I mean this epiphany point as I
told you is going to happen at some
point of your linguistic path and more
qualities you put into building a core
in your head the more brilliant does a
visiting point to the beat what why does
a quality work the quality of your work
is absolutely essential to learning
language well quality work is steady
efficient and not the heavy word that
you impose to yourself according to your
schedule
who's saying is that of building a core
in your head and set before knowing how
to schedule your work keeps you from
being a passive learner I'm subscribed
on what I do in another video but let me
share with you the reasons why this is
being is proving self-sufficient with me
in the first year I mostly focus on
listening to that language but I almost
immediately start writing and speaking
it I know it wasn't a huge amount of
material I think it is much more
efficient to listen to some material
very attentively
rather than flooding your brain with
hours and hours of stuff I will explain
later at this point I start writing that
language there a couple weeks after the
very first start mostly using Microsoft
Word by retranslated the text into the
target language from a lot like native
language due out to the language of
learning and then confronting what
you've done with the text after a week
put your brain in a position of
collaborating phrases directly in that
language and it is also their form of
autocorrection when you don't have a
teacher you if you write something and
then you just see what the difference is
you autocorrect yourself you know
it also helps absorbing grammar
effortlessly somebody says the grammar
is not important and they can learn
without a grammar book in answer to this
I think that grammar is important the
whole point is not whether grammar is
important not how one can absorb it
without effort without these bad nasty
epitome of grammar and how one can
absorb it without effort that is with a
stun it doesn't foresee any heavy an
Oracle grammar books and so forth which
I generally try to avoid as much as
again so with this simple retranslated
operation your brain fixes the structure
of the language and also provide the
script that your brain we use when
speaking that language I've been
wondering for a long time why literally
see written subtitles in my head and
speaking languages and I found out that
this is mainly due to this with the way
I do of learning
this way of learning them learning
languages having a script in your head
links sounds to letters and words and it
is a great advantage after three months
I started lever a ting phrase in my head
and it start doing the most important
things I talked even if I don't have a
native speaker in front of me imagine
having one in front of me and try to
think of what to say
introduce myself talk about the weather
family and so on there are some language
people when for Sidious
speaking to yourself not useful because
nobody is there to correct your
pronunciation and to remember to say I
think that this advice is not I think
does not good advice in the sense of
speaking to yourself but not better your
pronunciation but gets you fluent in
that language language is also a matter
of Catholicism the kids don't speak that
language it is simply because they
haven't developed a physical capacity of
doing that but as soon as you that they
do you can tell they create or you know
they want to be money
after years of adults we are ready to
create new sounds immediately my advices
listen to some audio material for a
couple months start writing and
translating from your language or the
target language and after another run
start having conversations into even
with yourself of course this has to be a
progressive work after year but it can
be much less array for a plenty of work
at this point your brain is ready to
absorb better a huge amount of inputs
we're just preparing your brain to do
the input like movies books and
newspapers and produce outcome more
efficiently both oral and written
conversations with native speakers if
you wonder why people immersed in some
language be more versed and some lemon
zest speak as fast the answer is very
simple because they're forced to speak
that language on a daily basis whereas
whereas living in your counter it makes
you lazy because you don't necessarily
need to speak it if you create your own
environment where you're immersed enough
language in that target language evening
for you still live in your own country
you will learn that language very well
anyway which leads to the final point of
this video how to create that
environment other speaking with some
Americans ask me who's happy to speak
English like that you've never been in
country and nervously not days before
for those who prayed who praised the mp3
as an incredible to think better Skype
sister reveal Auto material below tape
sounds quality was much worse it's been
rough it's been around for over 30 years
that Scott has been around for much less
Scotland's real tool for learning
languages when this wonderful Toledo
sprouts have no more excuse for getting
proficient in languages the conversation
with a native is an invaluable assets
once you've reached an intermediate
level there are many other things I'd
like to share with you and I will make
some other videos thanks so much for
to me and I love you see top